good morning and thanks for being with
us the uk is bolstering its military
presence in europe sending thousands of
troops along with dozens of tanks and
heavy artillery pieces in what's
described as one of the largest
deployments since the cold war the
british army personnel will join tens of
thousands of nato troops for joint
exercises across the continent aimed at
deterring russian aggression meanwhile
moscow has continued to launch missile
strikes all across ukraine well
ukrainian authorities have accused
russia of firing true cruise missiles on
kiev while the u.n secretary general
antonio gutierrez was visiting at least
10 people were injured
well concerns are being raised about the
safety of two more british nationals in
ukraine a day after it was confirmed
that a british soldier called scott
sibley had been killed in the country
while fighting for the ukrainians
the presidium network says that two men
working as humanitarian relief
volunteers were captured on monday by
russian forces at a checkpoint in the
southeast of the country
and ukraine's president vladimir
zelinsky has thanked u.s president joe
biden for his request for 33 billion
dollars in new funding to help support
ukraine saying that he hopes congress
would quickly approve the measure
president biden
president biden rightly said today that
this step is not cheap
the negative consequences for the whole
world from russia's aggression against
ukraine and against democracy are so
massive that by comparison the u.s
support is necessary
together we can definitely stop the
russian aggression and reliably defend
europe
well meanwhile new pictures have emerged
from the besieged city of mariopol
reportedly shown the aftermath of a
russian attack on a military field
hospital in the as of style steel plant
now the video was released by the azov
battalion and it shows injured people
being treated and soldiers digging
through the rubble the ukrainian
president's office said an operation is
planned to evacuate civilians from that
plant today
well let's bring in alex ross who's
joining us now from denver pro in the
very center of ukraine alex good morning
to you let's first pick up on the news
that we've had come into us this morning
though there's two british humanitarian
workers who are missing what more do we
know
good morning yeah this is an extremely
worrying development not least of all
for the families of these people we
don't have a huge amount of information
at the moment we know that they were
working
on humanitarian aid projects it's
believed that they were captured
by russian forces somewhere in the
southeast of the country now the foreign
office is working to try to get more
details at the moment and try to
obviously get their release but this
does of course uh present you know an
extremely difficult problem for the uk
government
uh at the moment but as i was saying
details are extremely scant at the
moment but i suppose as well it
underlines really the wider dangers that
many people are now facing in this
conflict there isn't a scrap of ukraine
that isn't at threat from russian
aggression it doesn't matter whether you
are in
an apartment building in odessa feeding
your three-month-old baby or whether
you're dug in in a trench uh in the
donbass you are um i suppose that threat
from russian grads rockets and cruise
missiles again that was underlined in
downtown kiev overnight
very large explosions uh there and the
timing of that of course is something
that perhaps we need to just pause
just pause a little bit and think about
this morning
at the time the un secretary general and
tony gutierrez was
being given a tour of the northern
districts places where russian war
crimes are alleged to have taken place
now president zielenski and many many
other people across this country think
that this was really
a signal by the russians mocking
the united nations as an institution uh
and also to a certain extent the world i
think the other thing
is well to reflect on uh in terms of
what that means is just
how failed the diplomacy is the peace
negotiations uh to try and stop the
fighting i think that's why we're now
hearing whether it's from london whether
it's from berlin whether it's from
washington um words really that you know
reflect that we are going to see
most likely this war continue
for many many more months if not years
okay alex rossi in denipro thank you
very much for that
all right and i'm joined now by the
international trade secretary anne marie
trevelyan and marie thank you so much
for being with us this morning let's
just pick up on what we heard from alex
there another two brits missing we had
one die yesterday and one is still
missing what's being done to get these
people back so the foreign office uh
obviously is very working very closely
uh with those in ukraine uh both uh to
make sure that you know the
identification is correct
and indeed to work with local
authorities and to support uh families
here you know as we've uh set out right
from the beginning uh we don't want
british nationals to go and uh fight but
there are many many ways in which so
many people and i think the the
heartfelt uh genuinely heartfelt anxiety
and appalledness that uh putin has uh
illegally invaded and is now a
continuing uh to bombard those areas
where he had uh stepped away is
something that quite rightly horrifies
the british public and there are many
ways that we can all support through
humanitarian through uh opening our
homes through supporting through uh the
financial channels but we don't want
people to go and fight but obviously the
foreign office is doing all it can
to support and identify these two people
i mean we're saying that now we don't
want people to go and fight that's not
quite what the foreign secretary said at
the beginning of this war is that she
said that she would support those who
wanted to go and fight for what she saw
as a just cause in ukraine she was wrong
to say that wasn't she at the time so
she she continued to uh explain after
that that uh we do not want british
nationals to go at the time obviously
the advice was to not go uh to rental
that remains the travel advice for
obvious reasons because it's a war zone
and we want to make sure
that people can show their support their
solidarity for ukrainians and for uh the
battle that those extraordinary people
are doing to fight for the freedom of
their country through all those other
ways and it is extraordinary how
generous the british people are being
both with their own their own homes with
their money uh with their time to
support the ukrainian families and just
a thought then on that uh british
support for ukrainians coming here that
scheme is still not working as well as
it should is it at the moment there are
still massive problems in bureaucracy in
ukrainians arriving
so uh the process has been slow and lord
harrington uh is working literally uh
day in day out night and day with his
team to make it flow um i think we've
had nearly 75 000 visas uh now granted
i've had uh two families arrived last
weekend into my constituency who've been
welcomed it's been so touching welcomed
uh by the whole community uh i mean in a
sense of warmth and affection and there
are more from their own community uh who
will be coming but we want to make sure
that all those uh who are coming will be
going to a safe place so local
councillors have been asked to obviously
go and uh check the uh homes being
offered we don't want anyone uh to be
found in a difficult environment where
they might be put under kind of any kind
of stresses so we want to make sure that
it's rigorous and that visa system is
working it has been cumbersome but lord
harrington is absolutely focused on it
and anyone who is uh watching who is you
know keen to be generous with their home
please do be in touch with the rmp if
you feel that the process uh is getting
stuck somewhere i mean cumbersome is one
way to put it is this a problem with
like civil servants not being in the
office
uh no this is a process because it was
set out as i say uh whilst we are uh you
know one of the most generous countries
in well wanting to welcome people in uh
and the home sector has set this out a
number of times we want to make sure
that we are both uh bringing people who
are who will be very traumatized and
very vulnerable into safe places so the
councils have been asked to do a number
of checks to make sure that the homes
are indeed at once they can save and
also uh making sure
that these uh refugee routes are not
going to be abused by those who wish to
come into the uk and do our citizens
harm absolutely right well look let's
leave ukraine there for a moment we must
talk about what's happening in
westminster at the moment your colleague
suella braveman described some a
minority of your colleagues as animals
for the way they behave in parliament do
you agree
so i think all of us uh as uh women in
parliament have uh been subjected to uh
inappropriate language uh to you know
wandering hands uh as well my granny
used to call it uh it doesn't it doesn't
change the vast majority of
the men i work with are delightful
they're you know committed
parliamentarians they're passionate
about the causes they fight but there
are a few for whom uh you know too much
drink or indeed a sort of you know a
view that somehow being elected makes
them you know god's gift to women that
they can suddenly uh please themselves
that is never okay that kind of behavior
disrespect for women and indeed uh some
of the uh you know the younger women who
are not parliamentarians who are part of
our you know parliamentary family that
is never okay it's never okay anywhere
it's not okay in westminster either and
you know we have had a number of uh you
know ways to help uh women now share
their anxiety the experiences they've
had uh following one from the metoo
campaign a few years ago we have now
started to make uh frameworks that
ensure that women can speak up but it's
still i think uh not as good as
fundamentally if you're a bloke keep
your hands in your pockets and behave as
you would if you had your daughter in
you'd hope that they would but you know
you set up that scheme five years ago
after me too it's not doing what it
should be doing is it this is still
happening so no it is going to be the
people can uh refer and indeed but it's
not deterring the men from behaving in
the way that there is an interesting
question this is what what is the what
is the relevance deterrent that would
ensure uh that those that minority and
it is a minority of men who think it's
okay to behave inappropriately would
feel the pain and using the whip
uh so well you know a number of times
that has been used and i i see that um
liam burn uh was uh you know formally
chastised this week for bullying another
entirely inappropriate uh way of
behaving in the workplace or anywhere i
mean these are these are just you know
ways behaving that are not acceptable
and those of us who have uh you know
public roles roles responsibility and uh
we are indeed you know should be uh
demonstrating what good behavior and
leadership looks like need to make sure
that we are all doing that so i am very
firm i'm very comfortable calling out
anybody who thinks that their wandering
hands are okay and i have done it a
number of times over the years so people
do that to me and i will always
encourage uh women to be to feel
empowered to say so publicly but that's
difficult for those who are younger and
where that power difference is very well
so we continue to champion them i
absolutely hope there is a place for
them to come forward and i hope they
feel confident that they can do that but
what it's more than wondering is this is
a guy who perhaps
was watching porn more than once in the
house of commons i mean that is
disgraceful behavior he should be sucked
well i mean it's it's just completely
unacceptable uh to be uh you know well
hey why's he got the time uh b uh why
does he think that's okay what you do in
the pride to your own home
as a as an adult it is a different issue
um so why is he still got the whip and
why does that so i haven't had a chance
actually uh to speak to politics i've
been
out about but i think
the issue is there and the
grievances committee uh system is now in
place and i know that the speaker is uh
very focused on getting towards this
issue and i haven't i haven't been able
to talk to anyone this week but it is
completely unacceptable
you know that the chief whip knows this
person's name you we i'm sure that
people senior members in the party know
who he is he was reported by two of your
colleagues he's still got the whip we
don't know who he is
why is that happening why is the party
being so slow to take action against
this person who was watching pornography
in the house of commons so as i say i
haven't had a chance to talk to chief
whip and i know that we are uh
the uh
ladies in question who apparently uh saw
this completely completely inappropriate
activity uh have been uh encouraged to
use the formal system in the house
commons to be able to report it and i
hope very much that they will or indeed
have i don't know um and that the system
will uh demonstrate if that was the case
exactly uh what the punishment should be
for that sort of inappropriate behavior
i mean you said you haven't spoken to
people about this and that's perfectly
fine but is your party doing enough do
you think should one will be done
uh i'm very very confident the chief
whip i'm a a great fan of uh christine
harris's uh will follow both working
with parliament and parliamentary
processes uh to make sure that that is
both robust and provides the support to
the uh women in question and that he
will take a decision that is appropriate
uh when it's right i mean you mentioned
the behaviour at the beginning you
mentioned this idea of wandering hand
it's much more than that it's much more
serious in many instances let's be clear
about that um but you also mentioned the
drink culture boozing at westminster now
people watching this will be amazed that
parliamentarians can go and have a drink
and then perhaps go back to work go and
have a debate speak with other
colleagues
do you think it's time to ban alcohol in
the house of commons because it seems to
be a real problem and enabling people to
behave in terrible ways so again for
most people that isn't the case we do
have when we have long sittings uh uh
when a monday you know in my world
starts at 8am with meetings and if we're
not voting until 10 it's a long day so i
will you know that i am fed by the house
of commons uh several times during the
day we have canteens we can go to and in
the evening if there is a pause there's
nothing wrong with you know having
having a drink with your colleagues a
chance to catch up and discuss you know
matters of the day it's those who uh you
know abuse and you know find the
drinking culture too strong that is not
okay and that's something that has
improved a great deal uh when you talk
to those who've been in parliament for
you know much longer than the vast
majority of have the culture was a much
heavier drinking culture than it was but
that sense of responsible drinking which
we advocate and i would advocate to my
kids and to anyone else is something
that we want to see yes throughout the
place and that's what we need to work on
at every level responsible drink is one
thing but you know we don't allow people
to drink and drive because most of us
won't drink and drive but some people do
so that's why we ban it now people in
parliament are drinking and behaving
badly shouldn't we bamboos in parliament
um i you know people can go around to
the red line up the road and go for have
a drink if they're waiting that's not
quite the same it's on site isn't it i
think probably heavily subsidized as
well um not particularly no uh but
actually the reality is uh that there's
nothing wrong i think in in the course
of an evening or at the end at the end
of a working day we vote at seven on a
tuesday for instance at the end of the
working day you might go
around the corner to a pub with your
mates after work as indeed you know many
people do
when you're going home you're not going
back to work where this stuff so there
is the challenge that it is with
parliament is that we are in this very
unusual location the key message and i
would say to colleagues and i have many
times uh
said to people is you know there's
nothing wrong with having you know a
drink with colleagues a chance to
discuss issues responsible drinking has
to be the way forwards and we know we
continue to try and improve that
absolutely okay international trade
secretary deal has been signed with
switzerland um we're able to do that
deal but we still can't get brexit done
what's going on there
so uh we have obviously our uh train
cooperation agreement with uh the eu and
that is uh all signed and sealed and we
continue now to work in the new
environment uh which is uh the uk as an
independent trading nation uh and we're
also now able to build those trade deals
as a result of being out of uh the eu
with nations across the world so we're
working on a trade deal with india which
will be a huge opportunity for british
businesses uh with uh the cptp which is
a great uh indo-pacific uh group of
eight a market of eight billion pounds
uh we've just signed a deal with
australia and with new zealand and a
digital economy agreement with singapore
a really exciting part the uk is leading
the world in helping business to go
digital which strips away cost both for
the business but also for the consumer
so we're working across the world now of
freedom that's been given to us since
brexit to be able to really provide as
many tools as businesses uh need and are
asking us for so that we can get much
better opportunities for our consumers i
mean that's all great but we still can't
sort out the border arrangements for
northern ireland why is that taking so
long and why have we decided not to push
it off until the end of next year so as
uh the
brexit opportunities ministers set out
we want to make sure that those inward
flows coming into the uk continue to be
smooth the discussions continue they're
led by
the fcdo uh on how to try and uh ensure
that those trade diversion issues that
we've seen in northern ireland is there
a cost issue
uh is it no it's it's a it's for
consumers it's a floatage um
so what the the idea of uh you know
opening borders and ensuring that trade
flow is that trade is there so northern
ireland businesses have been seeing
trade diversion it's a concern that they
have so the fcdo continues to have
discussions with you to find the right
ways uh to try and reduce those uh
problems and to make sure that trade can
flow as well as it could make things
more expensive for consumers the the
situation that's there so we want to
continue to make sure that we uh both
have those flows that are unencumbered
and that it works really well for
businesses and of course at the end of
the line is the consumer so uh more
friction uh can bring more costs so we
continue to work with the eu to find the
best solutions for that okay i think we
finally got there at the end it may be a
bit more expensive but we're not saying
that brexit is going to make things more
expensive of course anne-marie chevalier
international secretary for trey thank
you very much for being with us thank
you
all right let's take a look now at the
morning's newspapers and of course
ukraine is making many of the front
pages let's start with the front page of
the metro which features the british man
scott sibley who has been killed in
ukraine the financial times leads on joe
biden's plea to the u.s congress to
approve 33 billion dollars in extra aid
for ukraine
the u.s president's plans to increase
aid agency ukraine also feature on the
front page of the guardian
well the telegraph features the news
that britain is going to send 8 000
troops to eastern europe that's the of
course as we've been saying one of the
largest deployments since the cold war
i'll have more of those papers later and
we'll get the reaction later from a
former deputy secretary general of the
united nations that's lord mark malik
brown to that news the two missiles have
hit kiev or the u.n secretary general
antonio gutierrez was visited
[Music]
and we're going to hear from a doctor
about why so many gps are losing staff
and why some in general practice or even
taking their own lives and tell us what
needs to be done to prevent it
well labour's shadow chief secretary to
the treasury pat mcfadden will be with
us just after 8.
[Music]
now the premier of the british virgin
islands has been arrested in the u.s
city of miami on charges related to drug
trafficking and money laundering let's
uh bring in now aisha zahid is joining
us from outside the foreign office aisha
good morning to you what do we know
about this case right now
well he was detained in miami yesterday
as part of an operation being run by the
u.s
drug enforcement administration and in
fact local media are reporting that dea
agents uh posed as cocaine traffickers
as as part of mexico's one of mexico's
biggest drug cartels to help make this
arrest and we have had reaction from the
government the foreign secretary liz
trust has put out a statement in which
she has said i'm appalled by these
serious allegations this arrest
demonstrates the importance of the
recently concluded commission of inquiry
i have spoken to the governor of the
british virgin islands and he will be
holding an emergency meeting of the
territories cabinet later today he will
set out next steps tomorrow including
urgent publication of the inquiries
report now that inquiry was launched
last summer to look into long-standing
allegations of corruption and
misgovernment misgovernance
and on top of that now andrew farkey
facing charges of drug trafficking and
money laundering okay ayesha for now
thank you for that reporting
now the president of guyana has told sky
news that an apology is needed for the
role the united kingdom played in the
transatlantic slave trade it comes as
the early countess of wessex completes
their tour of the caribbean president
erephan ali has been speaking in
disguise shiman freeman powell
a royal tour intended to promote the
platinum jubilee
but for some it served as a reminder of
a painful colonial past
and as far as the president of guyana is
concerned it's time to say sorry
i think
an apology is needed
this was
one of the greatest atrocities
in human history
and those who suffered
in this atrocity are persons from the
region a lot of persons from the
caribbean region
and that suffering was not only immense
it was generational
and
a lot of wealth was derived from the
suffering a lot of benefits was derived
from the suffering
the slave trade was once backed by both
parliament and the royal family until it
was abolished in the
1830s what was once the empire became
the commonwealth and just last month its
future king addressed the sins of his
family's past
but was criticized for falling short of
an apology
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
the royal tours were intended to
strengthen the links between the uk and
the caribbean
but it seems they may have weakened them
with many announcing plans to become a
republic before calling for compensation
guyana made this move in the 70s and say
sometimes a reset is needed
it is not cutting links uh it is uh
renewing yourself uh
on this new path that uh understands the
history what are saying now listen
we are on our own uh our own path
and in this part we are equals and we
are going to
strengthen our relationship with you but
you know this is the way we're going to
advance
the royals and the brits in general are
still highly regarded across the
caribbean
but it's clear
that there is a momentum for real change
and the caribbean are no longer asking
for it it's being demanded
shimane freeman powell sky news
okay let's take a look at some of
today's other headlines and the
three-time wimbledon champion boris
becker could be sent to jail today when
he's sentenced later for flouting at
terms of his 2017 bankruptcy the former
world number one was found guilty of
transferring hundreds of thousands of
pounds from his business account and
failing to declare a number of
properties that he owns
the messaging app whatsapp has confirmed
that it's running as usual after more
than 40 000 people in the uk reported
issues with it
the issues began at around 9 00 pm last
night most of the problems were reported
in london manchester and birmingham
a report has found exclusions from
primary schools should be banned within
the next four years
the report from the former children's
commissioner says that the current
system is not working for every child
and has left at-risk children being
viewed as a problem
black children are
three times as likely to be excluded as
their white peers particularly black
boys um and this can be very young as
well i've spoken to parents over the
last few months whose children have been
excluded from primary school one mother
talked about her child he was excluded
17 times between easter and december
pupils with people sorry with arthritis
are being urged to lose weight and
exercise as the main therapies for their
condition new guidance from the nhs and
from the national institute for health
and care excellence says that people who
are overweight should be told their pain
can be reduced if they lose weight
the government is promising support with
the cost of electricity and high energy
usage businesses such as steel and paper
manufacturing ministers said that an
energy intensive industry compensation
scheme will be extended for a further 3
years and its budget will be doubled the
scheme has provided more than 2 billion
pounds in support to businesses since
2013.
now ministers say lessons learnt from
supplying millions of covered vaccines
in the uk will help tackle a shortage in
hormone replacement therapy it's feared
low stocks of hrt is causing some women
to feel suicidal as they deal with the
extreme symptoms of the menopause the
health secretary has appointed madeleine
mctiernan director general of the
vaccine tax task force to help
there have been calls for cultural
change in westminster amid claims of
bullying sexism and have one mp accused
of watching pornography while in the
house of commons now this morning the
international trade secretary told this
program that many women in westminster
have been exposed to inappropriate
language and even wandering hands
so i think all of us as women in
parliament have uh been subjected to uh
inappropriate language uh to you know
wandering hands uh as well my granny
used to call it uh it doesn't it doesn't
change the vast majority of uh the men i
work with are delightful they're you
know committed parliamentarians they're
passionate about the causes they fight
but there are a few for whom uh you know
too much drink or indeed a sort of you
know a view that somehow being elected
makes them you know god's gift to women
that they can suddenly uh please
themselves that is never okay that kind
of behavior disrespect for women and
indeed uh some of the uh you know the
younger women who are not
parliamentarians who are part of our you
know parliamentary family that is never
okay it's never okay anywhere it's not
okay in westminster either
well our political correspondent rob
powell joins me now rob good morning to
you so i'm retreating there saying that
none of this is okay but also saying
that she doesn't quite know where this
investigation is at yeah it was a pretty
bleak picture i thought that she was
painting saying that she's had to call
out a number of men over the years for
what she said was wandering hands i
think what makes it more depressing as
you pointed out to her is that
this is not new stuff five years ago we
went through the so-called pest minster
scandal
where change was promised a new
grievance scheme was set up that is what
anne marie trevelyan was referring to
when she talked about the ways that
people can
raise complaints
but i think the fact that this is still
happening for a start calls into
question whether that is working and
also if we look at the case we've been
looking at considering this week over
the mp um accused of watching
pornography in the house of commons well
we don't even know whether an
investigation has started yet because of
course witnesses need to go to this
scheme to start the investigation as
annemarie trevelyan said she doesn't
know whether that
has happened yet um also this morning
there's uh accusations complaints on
over the way this scheme has handled a
separate case of liam byrne who was of
course
suspended from the house for a couple of
days over bullying allegations and how
that was handled by the scheme as well
so i think big questions for how the
scheme operates complaints can take
months if not sometimes years to
investigate
all the while you've got someone still a
member of the conservative party still
working in westminster accused of these
um various very serious accusations yeah
and perhaps nothing being done just yet
alright rob thank you very much for that
for now now let's take you to china
where authorities there are continued to
impose strict coverage restrictions in
an attempt to prevent an outbreak of
coven 19 from spreading now all schools
are closing in beijing in a further
tightening of the measures there as mass
testing continues all across the capital
let's bring in our asia correspondent
tom cheshire joining me now live from
beijing tom uh good to have you with us
so look what's going on in beijing last
time you and i spoke it's all about
shanghai now it's come to beijing
yeah it feels like beijing is hanging in
the balance sunday night they all did
the mass testing of everyone in this
district chao yang that was three and a
half million people that was extended to
around 20 million people across beijing
doing three tests this week so trying to
map the spread of covert 19. what
they've been doing so far is increa
increasing these restrictions as you say
schools are now closing more gyms are
closing live entertainment venues uh
ordered to shut their doors uh and also
people asked to work from home where
possible what they're doing instead of
the full lockdown is what's happening
behind me here uh this is a compound
that has had a case and it's been sealed
off uh there are supplies coming in but
no one's allowed out they're only
allowed in the front bit of it and
that's what beijing's hoping to do these
sort of places are dotted all across
this district of chao yang beijing's
biggest district so rather than the
whole city going to lockdown they're
trying to persevere with this they're
around 50 cases being added today and i
think authorities are probably happy
with this approach if it stays at that
number that's testing 20 million people
only around 50 cases in beijing and as
you say they are trying to avoid that
shanghai lockdown that is going into its
sixth week a very very strict lockdown
there are signs it may be easing case
numbers have been coming down there
around 000 over the last 24 hours still
very high by chinese standards but some
districts being let out of that very
strict lockdown they can leave their
neighborhoods apartments and they can
wander around the streets there's not
much to do because everything is shut in
terms of restaurants and businesses but
there is a little sign of hope that they
are near the end of that ordeal beijing
the worry here is that we're really at
the beginning okay tom in beijing for
now thank you so much for that
all right let's return now to our top
story ukraine and the russian invasion
authorities have accused russia of
launching two missiles into kiev while
the u.n secretary general antonio
guterres was visiting the capital police
to say i'm joined now by the former
deputy secretary general of the united
nations that's lord mark malik brown
joining us live
lord brown thank you so much for being
with us this morning and good morning to
you i mean reports that these um
missiles have hit kiev while antonio
guterres was there what does that tell
us about russia's respect or lack
thereof for the united nations
well it tells us there isn't much uh you
know it follows on the secretary general
making a difficult visit to moscow
earlier in the week
where you know he was given a fairly
chilly reception and spoke up strongly
against what had happened in ukraine
um but there is a pattern to this uh
putin loves to find this like probe the
psychological weak points of his
diplomatic opponents angela merkel
famously when she visited him found that
he sort of unleashed a large dog on her
knowing her dislike and fear of dogs i
think this falls into the same category
in his first term as secretary general
antonio quiterious visited libya and was
absolutely frankly somewhat daunted when
tripoli was bombed during that visit
and it made him a much more cautious
diplomat according to those around him
for the rest of his first term uh he
finally kind of gets his courage back
goes to kiev and to moscow and hey
presto uh putin reminds him of that sort
of
floor psychological floor if you like at
the first term and maybe not
psychological flaw because a secretary
general should be able to expect to
visit during a conflict and have the
competence not be shooting rockets
around them so it is humiliating in a
way and i think the international
community not just europe but countries
everywhere will recognize they cannot
have their u.n secretary general uh sort
of treated in this
disrespectful casual and frankly
dangerous way
by putin and the russian regime
absolutely but i mean humiliating is one
way to put it doesn't it reveal as well
uh lord malek brown the impotence of the
united nations to have any effect
despite the fact that antoni containers
has been to moscow and kiev this past
week
well look i i don't think the united
nations and it's in you know it's
following on the backs of turkey of
president macron france of germany and
others who've tried
to secure a process towards a ceasefire
this is not a conflict tragically which
is ready for peacemaking by anybody let
alone the united nations neither side is
ready uh to make the concessions that
would require so he very much focused
his
non-public private efforts on securing
humanitarian corridors particularly
trying to find a way to get the
civilians
trapped under the plant in mario paul
the large steel plant a safe passage out
and you know in theory putin agreed to
that but there's been no sign on the
ground that even that very limited
humanitarian goal has been advanced so
this this remains a situation where the
russian word is not to be trusted uh and
you know where where the conflict is
gonna go on and of course frankly for
the u.n this is a pretty fundamental
moment
uh a lot of ambassadors of all u.n staff
in an open letter secretary general
described this as the un's league of
nations moment the moment at the
beginning just before the second world
war when that international mechanism
for peacekeeping the un's predecessor
was basically broken uh by conflicts in
abyssinia ethiopia
and in spain
and you know there are many who worry
that the un faces a similar moment over
a sort of crisis of legitimacy and
confidence and you know but crises are
sometimes moments of opportunity and i
hope member states will use this moment
to sort of refashion the u.n
for today's age where you have you know
one of the guarant original guarantors
of the un
uh the former soviet union now russia
but has become a rogue state a enemy of
the international law and order system
and where the u.n has to rise to the
occasion of dealing with that
yeah and lord malet brown then just a
thought then this morning about uh those
britons who uh are missing one dead
three missing in ukraine at the moment i
mean what as as a very senior diplomat
yourself sir what will be what will be
being done right now and what can be
done on the ground in a war zone to try
and make sure that those guys
can be returned home
well i'm sure every effort will be made
to get some kind of
limited prisoner swap and i'm sure
british diplomats are active on it i
think also it has to be said that when
people choose to go and you know fight
like this heroic and important though it
is they are taking real risks and it's
not going to be easy i suspect at this
moment to necessarily get them out we're
going to see a lot more of this i mean
this let's not kill ourselves this isn't
all probability as
foreign seculars trust and others have
said going to be a long run conflict
this is going to be a shadow over europe
for a very long period to come and it's
not going to stop at the borders of
ukraine we're going to see you know
steadying inclusion of neighboring
countries at least being destabilized if
not actually be militarily invaded
and so
you know we're going to brace ourselves
for a lot more moments like this
i mean where does this sorry mark my uh
lord brown where does this end then i
mean look you've given us your opinion
there do you think this is going to be a
long conflict so to completely respect
that opinion but where do you think this
ends well you know i now run an
organization the open society
foundations and we have huge investments
in ukraine around democracy and free
media and
human rights etc and you know people
like us are going to go on investing in
that agenda to make sure that the
threat that ukraine really posed to
russia which was never a nato strike
military threat it was always a one
about values and freedom and democracy
which was a challenge to this
dire regime next door the russian one
we've got to keep that alive and we've
really got to get this to a point where
perhaps not putin personally but those
around him
recognize this is a lost conflict
and it is you know time to settle and
you know that settlement may not be a
complete victory for ukraine because
settle the peace settlements rarely are
unless they follow a complete defeat of
one side by the other but we've got to
get to a point where serious diplomacy
can be allowed to fill the space and and
start making real proposals for getting
to peace and at that point at this point
putin really only contemplates
you know a a total victory at least in
the east and south and you know a a a
ukrainian surrender and that's not on
the cards but equally
ukrainians need to recognize that
they're going to have to provide
assurances to russia that they're not
going to become a front base
for uh for action military action or
otherwise
against russia so and and i think
they're willing to do that so i think
you know
in time we can get to the basis for an
agreement but you know equally we've got
to look in the wider geopolitical
context we've got to understand that
this is one front in a much more
threatening potential repartitioning of
the world between a sort of china russia
bloc and a western bloc and i think our
real determination in diplomacy has to
be to try to prevent that we had created
a world of a single global community
able to
deal with common problems whether it was
climate change or development or peace
and security we shouldn't let that world
escape us because of the behaviors of
ambitious nationalist political leaders
uh in certain countries we need to fight
for a shared world for all of us a
multilaterally governed world and you
know that's the real fight russia is a
little bit of a sideshow economy in
decline but one was still with nuclear
weapons so we need to fix this conflict
but as a prelude to fixing the wider
global
deterioration of governance and and and
international diplomacy that's occurred
okay lord mark brown really appreciate
your expertise this morning sir thank
you so much for being with us good day
thank you there is a dangerous shortage
of family practitioners in the uk as a
shocking new poll has found that one in
four gps say they know a colleague who's
taken their own life the rebuilds
general practice campaign is calling for
governments to deliver on a pledge of
six thousand new doctors to try and ease
pressure on police say i'm joined now by
dr rachel ward who was a gp in
oxfordshire and who was part of the
campaign now dr ward thank you so much
for being with us and good morning to
you so just tell us some more about this
campaign to try and help gps
good morning well yes we know that the
government made a pledge in their
manifesto to provide 6000 additional gps
because we know that we are severely
lacking in great britain but
unfortunately they have not met this
this um this promise and they've
admitted that they are not on track to
meet this promise but the problem that
we see is that there is no other plan in
place they haven't identified how
they're going to meet the workforce
problem or what else they're going to do
about it so we know that we have
significant problems in general practice
at the moment the demand is very high we
are losing gps all the time and so this
is having an outcome of poorer patient
care and issues with patient safety so
we really are raising the alarm bell
here to ask the government to recognize
this issue and come together with us to
form a plan going forward
i thank you for that dr wood but i
wonder where are we going to find these
extra doctors are we going to go from
universities are we going to recruit
from overseas where are they going to
come from
yeah that's a very good point i think
this is not going to be resolved
overnight um you know there are several
things going on here so we do need to
make general practice a more attractive
specialty for people to come into when
they are training in medicine at the
moment it isn't seen as an attractive
specialty because of all the negative
rhetoric about general practice
but also very importantly we are losing
very experienced doctors all the time
because of the immense workload because
of burnout and stress so that also needs
to be addressed we also need to stop
losing our gps to keep those workforce
numbers up but you're absolutely right
this is a complex issue that's going to
take some sorting out but the first step
is recognizing that that needs to be
addressed i mean dr will just lay out
for us then why do you think general
practices is so looked down upon i've
always thought if i was going to be a
doctor apart from being like a
high-flying surgeon being a gp would be
quite good
well i think you know over the last few
years it's very well known that we are
short of gps in in britain so we know
that the workloads have been increasing
all of the time and then sadly over the
last couple of years we've seen a huge
amount of negative press about general
practice and a recent survey showed that
actually patient satisfaction with
general practice and also the nhs is it
is at an all-time low incredibly after
the last couple of years so i think
people see it as a specialty which is
really up against it and may choose to
go somewhere else
and of course that will mean then that
the people in in communities are perhaps
missing out on that first point of
contact with a a gp with an expert
absolutely so we know that patients are
waiting longer for appointments having
real difficulty getting appointments
even
and when we see patients we have less
time with each of them because of the
huge numbers of people that we're seeing
each day on average in england a gp is
doing 46 appointments per day whereas
the recommended number is 25 so of
course that's going to dilute the the
attention and time that each patient
gets
all in all this is having a negative
impact on the quality of care that we're
able to deliver unfortunately